this is a production of cornell
university
so as chris said i am a former graduate
student from cornell and looking back on
my career those were some of my favorite
times
uh the times when i lived in ithaca and
then up in geneva with harvey hooke as
well
and um i got married in geneva my wife
and i got married on the lakefront up in
geneva and we look back on those times
as being some of our best friends and
some of the best times of my life
so i i just want to say especially to
the students of you who are there you
are so fortunate to be attending school
at cornell
it's really a fantastic place
okay so
if you know
my career at all you probably think of
me as an aspergillus nebulan geneticist
and much of my career i have
focused on that area i'm looking at
hyphal growth but i'm actually going to
tell a different story today because
i've recently become interested in uh
particularly kolokos from gram and
nicola
so i am a microscopist and a cell
biologist and
um kalatachakum really has amazing cell
biology it's probably even better than
the raspberry if you're in the field i
think kalatocha
there's a lot that can be done with
polytochmia
anyway i'm going to tell you about a
story with canadia the canadial coin
toss and we can see in this image two
different canadian depicted
and i'm trusting that my mouse
that i'm moving around here is visible
to you all if it's not then please
somebody yell at me so i can figure out
how to fix it looks good okay thank you
and there are two canadians here one of
them is stationary and therefore i would
call it attached the other one is not
stationary and you can see that because
subsequent pictures that are depicted in
this are showing a blurring particularly
at the tips of the spore
and so this is where this concept of the
coin toss comes from is that there is
roughly a 50 50 selection mechanism for
the attachment of these spores to their
substrate and so i'm going to tell you
how we got to that conclusion in today's
talk
okay so
as most of you are probably aware call
it patrick of gram and nicola is an
ascomycete that causes diseases
various diseases of corn
um it's one of the top 10 most
economically relevant fungal pathogens
it causes foliar lesions on corn plants
but also is associated with stock rot
which causes the lodging of the stalks
and makes it impossible to harvest the
corn which is so it's very economically
damaging it's one of the greatest
sources of yield loss among these
pathogens resulting in tens of millions
of bushels to be lost each year
and i pulled this image out of a review
article
by
our very own dr breggstrom
okay so uh my interest is in the early
events of
the production of spores and in sport
germination and so let's take a brief
overview of what happens here um so
colitochrome produces two types of
canadian
there is a microcanadia that are often
called ovocanidia in the field
that are are not going to be part of
this talk because they're not part of
this mechanism that we talk about
all canadia are thought to be involved
in the dispersal of the organism within
the plant
but the dispersal outside of the plant
and to the plant is mediated by the
macro canadia which are also called
balcate canadia due to their shape here
and those are the spores that we see in
this image
there are these crescent shapes for
when the spores germinate
typically you'll see one germ tube
emerge
that very quickly under appropriate
conditions very quickly that germ tube
will stop polarized growth and begin to
differentiate the infection structure of
the appressorium as we see in this image
and then
it will penetrate its host using a
melonized aprasoria
using a mechanism that is very similar
to the better characterized system of
magnaporto or pericularia arising so it
uses melanin-derived turgot pressure in
order to penetrate
and sometimes you can get a
septation in the spore in order to get
multiple afresoria forming from the
spoon
and then once it penetrates the host
you'll get ramification of hyphae
throughout the maze tissue as we see in
this image where the maze tissue is
stained red in a gfp expressing strand
of colostrum shows us where the hyphy
are growing through
the infected host
okay several years back i was along with
a grad student a former grad student of
mine chile wong we uh created a um life
act strain of palatakam so life act is a
reporter that shows us in live cells the
actin cytoskeleton
so these next few images we're going to
see are showing us of what the behavior
is of the actin cytoskeleton during
these early events of germination
so we see up here a dormant spore
pre-germination spore that already has
this well-defined actin cytoskeletal
network running from tip to tip
as the sport germinates and here i'll be
showing a time lapse and this is sort of
setting the stage for the types of data
that i'll be showing you throughout the
talk
this is a time lapse video where a
picture is taken approximately once a
minute and then is being played back at
a much faster rate so we're seeing hours
and minutes represented in the video
but in this video we see the germination
of a felcate spore where the actin
cytoskeleton is highly polarized
um and i'll wait for it to loop back
around again and we can begin from the
beginning of the sequence
we have a highly polarized actin
cytoskeleton in the tip of the german
tube that actin retracts to a septum as
the septum is differentiated within the
spore and then once the septum
is delineated the actin then migrates
back out to polarize in the growing gym
too
so that's germination
here now we're going to look at
afrisorium formation in a similar time
lapse these time lapses are
approximately three hours long so the
septum has already formed in this time
lapse and we now see polarization of the
actin cytoskeleton
that then depolarizes as the germ tube
begins to swell to form an aposorium
and the actin all then relocalizes to
the septation site as a septum
delineates the apersarium from the spore
and then the final
time lapse in this sequence will be
looking at an apricorium from the point
of septum formation to the point of
penetration peg formation so the actin
was localized to the nascent septum the
septum forms
actin redistributes into the
appressorium and now it begins to
localize to the penetration poor as a
penetration peg begins to form
so the point of all this is to show you
that all of these developmental events
require the actin cytoskeleton
and likely the trafficking of cellular
components on the actin cytoskeleton to
these sites of growth as the cell
grows and differentiates
so my uh department just got a new
building about two years ago we moved
into a new building
and along with that new building um some
of us were fortunate enough to get new
equipment and um i'm no exception to
that i got a shiny new confocal
microscope
that has all of the bells and whistles
um so if there is a piece of
technology available on a confocal
microscope it's on this microscope
so this has really been a boon for my
career since moving into this new uh
building because the types of questions
that i can ask have greatly expanded
an example of that here is we see a
growing hyphy of kolatoch from drama
nicola in which we're imaging sites of
endocytosis so each one of these foci
are actually the sites of endocytosis
and unfortunately i won't be talking
about endocytosis in this talk but that
has been one of the focal points of my
career for the last 10 years
um but we have this nice new microscope
that allows us to ask questions with
even greater detail
than we have done so before
so moments ago when i was talking about
these early events germination i showed
you a dormant or pre-germination score
of of kalatachan gram and necula this is
the macrocanadium or sulfate canadian
and it has this pre-formed actin
cytoskeleton that runs from tip to tip
now we noticed that when we uh did the
study five or six years ago
but we were not able to go into any
greater detail of what this preform
cytoskeleton might be doing
and the new microscope has allowed us to
take another look at this
and so in this movie here that i'm going
to show you
this is a z-stack or a three-dimensional
projection of a spore and we're rotating
it so that you can see
that the actin cytoskeleton is actually
asymmetric within the spore
so it is on one face of the spore not on
the other face of the floor and i have a
visual aid for this
my visual aid is somewhat comical it's
this crunchy banana
but it's essentially a falcate canadian
and i trust that you all can see this
somebody please shout at me if you can
um but in this banana which is
representing the falcon canadium i've
drawn with a sharpie yeah i can
cytoskeleton that's on one thing
so in the image we're seeing this four
red heading which is and you're seeing
the actin cytoskeleton which is on just
one face of the floor
so this was the first
when we imaged it this way
is when we realized that maybe there is
something to this asymmetry so we
started to look at what could be the
possible function mechanism for this
asymmetry
um next we decided to look at spores as
they were formed on the petri dish so
kala tachycam
when grown in on auger will make these
sort of uh erupted pustules out of their
cerviline that has this buoy matrix in
which the canadia are secreted into from
the asservulus
and so what we're looking at here are
mature spores
within that gui matrix just inverted
onto the microscope so that we can see
them
and i hope you will agree with me that
the predominance of all of these spores
have that actin cytoskeleton already
known
there are a few instances in here like
maybe up here where maybe you would say
the skeleton cytoskeleton is not there
um but i think that's probably a trick
of the focal point
so the act of cytoskeleton is preformed
on pre-germinations for
uh next we looked at a young developing
a surveillance as it was producing with
canadian
and so in the center of this image we
have um canadia that are being produced
and are still attached to the
kinetogenous cells giving rise to those
spores
and they're revealed with a cell wall
stain that shows a blue cell wall
and so all of these nascent canadians
that are still in the process of being
formed do not have that cytoskeletal
element
but all of the mature canadians that
have been released from these
canadiaogenous cells
do have that pectin cytoskeleton
so production of the actin cytoskeleton
occurs early
in the development of the spore just
after it is liberated from the
canadiaogen itself
and to verify that claim that i've just
made
in this sequence we're going to look at
a time lapse of a canadium as it is
being produced
so in the image we see the kinetiogenous
cell here
and a young nascent candidium as it's
being produced from that kinetiogen cell
and this image actually has three pains
we cannot see the gfp channel
at this stage because the gfp is not
being produced so we have gfp we have
transmitted light and then the overlap
and i'll play this image
so this is at 15 minute intervals for
several hours and you can see
development of the canadium from that
canadian cell
as it reaches its terminal length it
begins to introduce that curvature
characteristic of the falcate canadia
and we still do not see the act in
cytoskeleton
but right about now as the canadian is
separated from the canadian cell you'll
start to see that active cytoskeleton
form up and you can then see the next
canadian being produced from the
canadiogenous cell
concomitant with that
so i'll play that again this is kind of
an amazing feat of grad student
ingenuity to get this image
this is the newest grad student in my
lab holly vetsel who was able to get
this sequence
of a developing canadian of
kalatosh from gramanicum
so still no act in cytoskeleton until
the spore is released from its
kinetiogenous cell and immediately
deposition of that
point to point
at an array
begins to occur
in this image we are using an inverted
microscope so imagine that my finger is
the lens and we're looking at spores
settling down towards the limit
so we're watching sporus cell
and as this loops through you will see
that some spores attach to the coverslip
immediately this one and this one both
attach the instant they make contact
with the substrate but some spores
remain unattached you can see these
continuously
vibrating moving around in a
brownian-like motion because they are
unattached
and so
this is roughly a half and half
situations for attachment
and i hope you can also see that those
spores that are attached have actin
within the focal plane nearest to the
substrate that we're imaging and those
that are not attached
lack that acting cytoskeletal element in
the focal plane of an imaging
so when not agitated
we resolve in roughly half of the spores
attaching to a substrate
and here that is depicted uh numerically
in graph form and this is kind of a
complex graph so i'll go through this
the gray line i'm sorry the um the black
bar graph is showing us the percent of
spores that are attached
over time so zero hours through 15 hours
and you can see that attachment hovers
in the neighborhood of 40 to 50
attachment no matter the time and this
is important that the spores remain
undisturbed in order to see this 50
attachment rate as soon as the spores
are disturbed the percent attached will
change
on the line we see of the percent
germinated so this is the next concept
that these spores
must be attached in order to germinate
so if the spore is attached then we
achieve germination of the spores
so
at zero time we've got zero germination
but it's up in the 40 to 50 to 60 range
over several hours after the spores
become attached
but with the dotted line here we see
that germination does not occur at all
on any spores that are unattached and
we've left this over the weekend so 48
hours or longer on spores that are
unattached remain unattached if they
were undisturbed they remain unattached
and they remain on germany
okay so more pictorial evidence here
we're looking at the same two spores in
two different focal planes
so the first is the focal plane nearest
the surface
and so you can see that actin
cytoskeletal array running from point to
point nearest the surface in the
attached spore
and there's no observable actin
cytoskeletal array in the unattached
spore
if we go to the top focal plane of that
spore
the same two spores
we have the actin cytoskeletal array
still exists in the unattached spore but
it is on the wrong face of the spore
so again i'll use my banana scrunchie as
my
pictorial demonstration just to make
sure we're all on the same page the
sharpie representing the acting
cytoskeleton element
if the spore is on the surface on that
face it's attached but if the
cytoskeletal element is up the spore
remains unattended
okay um and so here's uh some
evidence for that in numeric form
if um a spore is attached then it likely
has it has the actin cytoskeleton on the
bottom the rest of the surface the spore
is unattached and that organized actin
is at the top of the floor
and this is uh fully reproducible
and um we do occasionally see attachment
when the actin is at the top and i'll
explain that in a moment there is a
small amount of attachment using another
mechanism that i'll explain when we get
there
okay so this up led us to make the
proposal of the connection of quantums
and so here is a graphical
representation of one of these fours
and it wasn't until we thought of this
in three dimensions because of our
microscope that can allow us to achieve
three-dimensional imaging
um that we realize that that active
cytoskeleton is cited so in this image
we're looking at the points of the spore
facing towards us so again my banana
rather than looking at it like this
we're looking at it like this
and when this spore settles through
water these are splash dispersed spores
it's going to settle with the fat face
that's four down and when it hits the
surface it rotates this way or rotates
this way
and depending on the orientation of the
actin cytoskeleton will determine if it
attaches immediately to the surface or
if it never attaches to the surface
okay so digging through the literature
we found a review paper by dr bergstrom
and nicholson
and in that review paper they addressed
some older literature
where the extracellular matrix of colic
hydrogen was addressed
and
so these spores are secret are they're
liberated into a matrix on the um from
the cadiogenous cells
and so we're dealing with this matrix
which is this extracellular matrix
but also when the spores begin to
germinate they kind of secrete an
adhesive matrix around the germline as
well and i think that that's what's
being dealt with
[Music]
but so it was previously characterized
that the extracellular matrix is
composed of glycoproteins glucans and
amino acids
and so we scratched our heads a little
bit about how we might be able to
utilize this information on the
microscope
and that led us to some concanavalion a
which is a lectin
that binds to
glucans
and so this is a protein that binds to
glucans that can be conjugated to a
fluorophore so in this case we used
tritc tritzy which is a red fluorophore
and so con a binds to glucan and in this
image we have i'm using three colors so
first of all i'm using a cell wall stain
called solar phenol that stains the cell
wall of blue so we can see the canadia a
little better
and this is actually a
confocal based fungal cell wall stain
that um harvey hope developed so he was
the originator of the use of this die
that's gaining widespread use in the
fungal community
so here we have con a which is binding
to glucans and i hope you'll see that
there is a strip of glucan on the
canadians
and
when we then
with the other channel image life act so
the acting gfp
you can see again our tip to tip
acting cytoskeletal array within the
canadian
and then we do the overlay over in this
image
and i hope you will agree with me that
there is a one-to-one correlation
between the presence of the actin
cytoskeletal array and this glucan
binding kane reactive moiety which we
assume is an adhesive
at this stage we assume is an adhesive
and this image i think is just
absolutely dynamite because it shows
spores and all three possible
configurations with actin up actin down
adhesive up adhesive down
and then also the rare occasions when
the geometry of the cell
allows the spore to settle with the
adhesive not in contact with the surface
but also not facing up
but again the point of this is that we
have a glucan moiety associated with the
active cytoskeleton
and here again is one of these
three-dimensional images through the
spore and then through the magic of
computer assistance we're rotating that
three-dimensional projection of the
spore
and again i hope you will see that that
um secreted glucan or the secret the
glucan moiety is uh directly correlated
to the presence of that hacking
cytoskeleton
so our presumption would be that it's
being secreted by components running on
that actin cytoskeleton
but we have not actually proven that
and just to make sure because sometimes
seeing the video is not immediately
obvious to everyone i've got my banana
and what we're looking at is the spore
doing this
and now the strip on with a banana
represents both the actin cytoskeleton
and that flu can con a reactive moisture
when i showed you the percentages in a
graph earlier i said that sometimes we
hit numbers that aren't quite fifty
percent and i think the reasoning for
that is actually revealed in this image
because the glucan moiety is also
present
at the tips of the spores
and sometimes spores aren't shaped quite
properly they'll be bent like this or
this and however they settle they're
always foundation
and so there is a non-coin toss element
to
selection for adhesion
okay here's another time lapse where
we're watching the spores settle down
towards us on an inverted microscope
and i'll let this play through again and
hopefully pause it in just the right
place
well
so
if i could get it paused in the right
place which i don't think i can oh there
we go okay
um you can see the con a reactive boot
can strip
it's facing the same direction on those
two spores a and b but as the movie
plays you can see the spores settle in
opposite directions of each other
b is settling
with con a down and the spore attaches
and a is settling with the con a
reactive strip up and it does not attach
so it's the settling of the spore which
determines whether it will attach or not
okay since this is a glucan our
presumption because con a binds to
glucans our presumption is that this is
a glucan moist
we decided to treat spores with an
enzyme to determine whether that strip
is the actual adhesive element
and so on the left we see what's
familiar to you now this rotation of a
spore
and
it's our control where you can see the
actin cytoskeleton as well as the con a
reactive glucan
reactive strip
and to the right of we have used
enzymes we actually still have a stash
of melvezyme in my lab so that's our
glutenase is noah's not
and you can see that that con a reactive
strip has been removed from the spore
with novazon treatment
and there's some debris in the field and
that's actually very lucky for this
image because it shows us that
um the kane
is actually present in this preparation
because you can see the debris in the
background reacting with the
but the strip is entirely removed
so here is further confirmation that the
strip is composed of at least in part of
glucan
and now the image that you see to the
right is of the
gluconase treated spores
and i hope what you will see is that
almost all of the spores in this image
are con attached
so there are rare occasions in here
where spore looks to be immobile like
below this strip that's playing here it
isn't a mobile spore
but for the most part these are all
moving with the flow of liquid inside of
the chamber that we're using here
so no kanas reactive strip
composed of boot cans there's no
attachment and then that's quantified
over here
control is roughly 50 attachment
enzyme treated we get close to zero at
fashion
okay next we wanted to know uh since the
previous study i mentioned before from
bergstrom and nicholson had showed that
there is a secreted adhesive from
kalakotram we wanted to know um
the the timing of the importance of this
con a reactive strip to attachment
and the way to get it that would be to
fix the cells and the data that i'm
showing here are formaldehyde fixed
cells
so the canadian were treated with
formaldehyde to kill them and then
attachment assays were performed
and in the
it's indistinguishable of the percent
attachment that's achieved um when
formaldehyde is used to kill cells
versus living cells so that to me
indicates that the liberated spores that
we
that we harvested are already attachment
competent
so this is not
sorry i got a battery low warning i want
to make sure i get this thing
plugged in i'm not sure why that would
be
yeah my charger is not working
well hopefully this is gonna
hopefully i can finish asking for my
battery done
okay um next uh we wanted to see can we
flip spores and cause them to attach
and the answer is yes so what we're
using here is a micro controller
that is controlling a motor that we got
out of an old cell phone
so you're all familiar with turning your
ringer off on your cell phone and
somebody calls you and your cell phone
vibrates and there's a little motor in
the phone that does that that we have
attached to a slide here
and it's controlled by a microcontroller
that controls the
length of vibration the time of
vibration as well as the intensity of
the vibration
and in this image what we're going to
see is uh you can see the vibration
happens in the video as it occurs
and if we look across this field you can
see for example here is an unattached
spore that flips over and becomes
attached
here is an unattached spore that doesn't
flip over and it remains unattached
here's an unattached spore that doesn't
flip over it remains unattached
here is an attached spore that remains
attached
but the main the punch line of this
movie
is seeing that spores can flip over and
immediately attach
upon that flipping
sorry i'm entirely distracted by my
charger not working
okay um so uh we address this in another
way by um pipetting a solution of spores
onto a substrate allowing them to settle
i'm quantifying because we're working
with an inverted microscope quantifying
attachments
and then after various time periods
using the pipettor to agitate the liquid
solution
and so that's what we're seeing here so
no disturbance with a pipettor we've got
roughly 50 attachment as shown with this
gray line here across the board
but if we allow them to settle and then
disturb after five minutes we achieve
much higher percentage attachment 80 to
90 percent attachment
if we allow them to settle for 10
minutes it remains at roughly 50 percent
attachment and then 10 minutes of
disturbance you get nearly 100
impressions
and then here is allow them to settle
and
quantify for 15 minutes and we remain at
50 attachment
and then it goes to a high level of
attachment after the disturbance so we
can flip these spores whether we use a
cell phone motor or a pipettor and they
will attach
okay so what does all this mean
we think that the mechanism that we're
seeing here is uh
to enhance the dispersal of the fungus
so if
all spores attached upon initial
settling of the spores then the size of
the infection court would only be as big
as um the rain droplet that settled the
initial spores
we think again this is about uh
dispersal of the spore
so if spores were to settle and all
attach in that rain droplet then um
you're going to be dealing with only
very small lesions at any one time but
the fact that only some spores will
attach initially then if the spore if
the droplet of water containing spores
runs down the leaf or falls off the leaf
to another leaf or another plant
or maybe a subsequent raindrop splashes
this
or maybe the rain droplet dries out and
we have some unattached dried out spores
that will then rehydrate and be
dispersed again with a subsequent dew or
rainy pen
all of these things can then result in
further dispersal of the spores
um so the this is all about then
dispersal and selection for greater
dispersal we're still working on ways
that we could work quantify this so um
one thing that we've tried is to look at
coverslips you know i'm kind of a i'm a
benchtop scientist and a microscope
scientist so i think of ways of doing
this artificially
um so we looked at these long cover
slips
at various angles
and if we've got a flat cover slip then
we get about 50 attachment if it's
angled slightly so the drop never rolls
and all the spores are more or less
distributed
in in the initial droplet but if we've
got a greater angle on the coverslip
allow the spores to adhere or to settle
then we get some spores in that initial
droplet and then of course this is kind
of expected i guess but as that droplet
moves down the coverslip you get
deposition of spores down the coverslip
as it runs
and so i'm i'm still working on ways to
model this
and um we have done some we've tried to
do this on corn leaves as well but the
microscopy gets exponentially more
difficult to achieve if we try to do
this on corn lanes
so then
in conclusion then we've got our uh an
ideal coin toss model that we see here
is now
enhanced by also having the presence of
that adhesive strip
presumably composed of glucans
and so we've got this polarized actin
array that's pre-formed and
pre-germinated canadia
but we know that the production of that
actin array occurs when the spores are
liberated from the canadian itself
the actin array tracks a discrete area
of adhesive
we don't know yet if that actin array
would be the
distribution network that allows the
secretion of that
adhesive material or is it actually more
of a sensing mechanism
and so i also told you that these spores
don't germinate unless they're attached
so the spores must sense in some way
that they have become immobilized
and that actin array may also be
participating in that sensing mechanism
so the initial attachment is passive
that
adhesive is pre-formed and attachment
occurs instantly upon contact with the
surface
attachment is cited
so this likely enhances sport dispersal
um so outstanding questions uh what are
the relationship between the acting and
the adhesive i've just sort of mentioned
this is the act in the distribution
network probably yes but also probably
the actin is as part of the sensory
network associated with
with the spore realizing that it's
become
immobile
um what's the relationship between this
and the previously characterized
secreted adhesive
so i have a collaboration with some
physicists that do raman spectroscopy
and we're actually in the process of
using raman spectroscopy to try to
determine what's in the adhesive
so how does that adhesive of the spore
tips affect coin toss it isn't actually
perfectly 50 50 attachment and that's
because of the adhesive that we see at
the tips and that's going to make
modeling of this much more difficult and
i've got a
epidemiologist who's helping me
with the conceptualization of this
on the effect of wettability so we've
been using this mostly on coverslips um
we don't know yet the really the effect
of this on a corn plant
and the corn plants have got the the
leaves are going to be waxy because of
the cuticular wax and they're going to
be more hydrophobic and we don't know
yet the effect of that on on this
dispersal mechanism
and
i'm going to play this video this is
really a mystery to us so we've got the
acken array here
and this is using the dye fm4 that shows
us a membrane within the cell
and i hope that what you see in this
pre-germinated cell is the dynamic
collapse of that hacking pythoskeleton
and it's actually being achieved by this
membrane bound organelle that is
trafficking on the actin cytoskeleton
almost like pac-man gobbling it up
and i've shown this to some of my
colleagues at work on actin cytoskeleton
we have yet to come up with a convincing
hypothesis for what that
structure might be that's actually
causing the collapse of the actin
cytoskeleton
but we do see this
often enough in the cells to know that
the dynamic collapse of the action is
actually happening amongst these cell in
pre-germinated cells
and we don't know the mechanism for that
at this time either
okay so finally then i just want to
mention again that my history has come
full circle so i was a grad student with
harvey hoke and i used to work on spora
attachment so here's a 1999 paper with
me and harvey
in which we were characterizing an
adhesive sheath on the spores of the
black rod of grape fungus
and i will also point out that this
inquiry took us then to try to look at
calcium signaling
during that spore attachment and we
largely failed at that but i'm pointing
this out because i actually co-authored
a paper with gillian probably gillian
you don't even remember the favor
all the way back in 2001 and um my dear
friend and and departed colleague nick
reed was also an author on this paper
okay so with that then i will show you
that these are the people that actually
did the work of joe vasely as a senior
grad student in my lab who'll be
graduating soon he has a fantastic
microscopy skills and will be looking
for a postdoc
if anyone up there it needs a
microscopy-oriented postdoc he would be
a good person to do it
um ellen and
hope are two undergraduates to work on
the project and then ollie up here is
brand new grad student who's going to be
taking over from jail on the project
and i think with that then i can end
and ask if there are any questions
outstanding job brian thank you so much
and questions
return to my comment
which you missed brian due to your
computer malfunction
did you learn more from chris
at michigan state or from harvey
hope while you were
a graduate student here
don't answer
you know i learned from both of them so
that's unloaded
but
you know i have focused on microscopy
for most of my career
i certainly inherited that phenotype
from harvey
yeah i think
my approach to this presentation was a
very harvey-like approach to the
presentation
and um a serious question
uh
have you stained for dna
[Music]
in the matrix
perhaps of those canadian
uh i have not
what would you expect to find
secreted dna
yeah
maybe
okay
well we have we've tried to use dapi
because we are hoping to image nuclei as
this happens to see when mitosis is
triggered relative to germination
and daphy doesn't work that well in live
cells and so really what we would need
is a histone marker for that that
probably wouldn't help us with secreted
dna i guess dappy probably would work
with that we could
i don't think i had that in mind when we
looked at those dappy stains for us so i
may not i may have missed it if there
was dna in the secreted matrix
thanks
gary
hey brian i really enjoyed your seminar
uh your your uh microscopy just blows me
away
uh
i a couple of things i for one thing you
solved the mystery that for many years
working with with that organism
when we're trying to optimize inoculum
production uh we looked for german
ability i.e viability uh using um you
know watch slides and and looking at
germination
uh at six or twelve hours and we're
always frustrated why couldn't we get
that germination rate higher so you've
answered a great mystery there
uh
you know when we're trying to achieve
nearly 100 percent germination we will
routinely deposit spores and then
agitate it with the pipeline right and
then you'll get nearly 100 germination
yeah it's really that's fundamental
stuff that's that's amazing a couple of
things i was thinking about as far as
some of the implications possibly
of some of your findings and i agree
with the dispersal thing
um
two things occurred to me
um to enhance the chances for uh stock
rot infection
uh enough of the uh the spores need to
get past the leaf blade and make it down
behind the leaf sheath to be near the
stock grind so you know they don't all
get bound up on the on the leaf blades
maybe
i don't know but maybe that would allow
for uh
more of the spores to get in behind the
leaf sheath
you know that's just a that's just a
thought
um the other thing that occurs to me is
that ralph nicholson did uh work with uh
found a germination self-inhibitor
when uh
when the uh spores are all crammed
together in that a servulus
uh that probably are prevented from
germinating
uh but the dilution factor uh the idea
that you know a clump of spores landing
in a droplet
some would adhere and some would be
allowed to wash off would be a dilution
factor too uh to kind of dilute out
whatever germination self-inhibitors
might be there and that that that's a
mechanism you might think about a little
bit too
going along with dispersal but anyhow it
was it was fascinating i loved it brian
thank you
that's a really good point about the
self-germination inhibitor being diluted
as part of this coin toss mechanism as
well so i i think i want to add that to
the conceptualization of it
cathy
hey brian nice to see you hi good to see
you
um i i guess um i always ask impossible
questions um so i wanted to ask like how
do you think this is like a kind of
universal thing like all those fungi
that have like curved
spores you expect to find a similar
mechanism
i would not be surprised if we saw it
with other fungi how universal it is i
don't know
okay um yeah i think that it's um
not outside of uh i don't think it would
be wild thinking to think that um fungi
that cause foliar lesions that are water
dispersed
might have similar mechanisms and for
that matter maybe even aquatic fungi we
think of fungi that you know float down
a river and get snagged on on leaf
debris or whatever
i think anytime there's water dispersal
that a mechanism like this might be at
play
um whether an aerial dispersed fungus
like you know the fungus i'm used to
working on aspergillus nebulance i'm i'm
not sure the mechanism would work
similarly and i find it's like that
well it's so interesting and so
beautiful i love when i love to see the
sort of living fungus because i usually
just kill them when i look at them
so thanks for that yeah thank you
tristan
hi brian
hello i really enjoyed your talk and
your microscopy is absolutely stunning
thank you
i don't know if i might have missed this
during the talk i was really curious
so when canadia are being liberated from
their respective conditional force have
you been able to observe any patterns
and how the spores determine where the
actin initially concentrates whether
there is a
factor light or
initial orientation or is that acting
concentration more or less random yeah
that's a great question we've actually
tried to ask it oh back to my banana
model my camera is in a different place
here
um
so really what the question is i think
is is the acting right or left-handed
right so there is a sidedness to the
point there's the scar from the canadian
cell and there's the tip so we can
distinguish those and we've tried to
address is the actin always made on one
side or the other
and i'm not sure we've convincingly
addressed it yet but the preliminary
data we have shows that it can be formed
on either side but there doesn't seem to
be a preference of sightedness for which
side it forms on
all right
well i think many of us get to connect
with brian throughout the day which we
look forward to and let's all thank
brian again for a really great seminar
thank you very much
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu